各位同学
今天授课的内容是歌词词汇的累积与收集
所谓工欲善其事
必先利其器
运脚本这本工具书我们要自己整理
自己收集
当我还是新人的时候
我就自己收集自己的工具书
什么书呢
韵脚本
所以今天要跟大家分享的是如何去收集
怎么收集
它有分两大类
因为我当初是新人的时候
我发现说市面上没有卖这种歌词
韵脚本
怎么样的歌词内容
怎么样的韵脚
然后怎么样的片语分门别类
没有这种东西自己收集
我觉得自己收集也是好事
因为你会更有记忆
你会更明白哦
哪边的资料库在哪里
哪边的数据
所有的数据是这个类别的一些韵脚在哪里
你自己可以活泼的运用那通
当到了我们这个应该讲说阶段吧
有时候已经不需要了
因为基本上我脑海中已经有已经有数据库了
那新人还是需要
今天跟大家讲的是怎么收集法
首先有两大类
第一个是数据库
就不用手写了
可以用电脑打字
怎么打字呢
比如说an跟on一个听觉的同韵脚
你就尽其所能的把这个听觉韵脚的相关字
打出来
比如说可能悲伤沮丧
脸庞风霜
或者说沙滩河岸港湾都可以
尽其可能的收集齐备
这个很像建筑材料
你知道吗
就是说你的建筑材料越多
你的家里的装潢的布置
它的弹性跟空间越大
我有彩绘玻璃
我有罗马地砖
我有文化石
我有一些直灾
我有特别的窗帘
我有地毯
基本上就在我仓库了
所以我这整个空间的布置跟结构是很多元的
同学们注意看一下屏幕上的一个韵脚表
这个韵脚表到时候会帮助很大
因为呢他用听觉去区分我们韵脚的取舍
或者是变化
这个其实会帮助你在创作歌词的时候
有一些关键字不虑匮乏
你越罕见的句子
你自己把变成数据库
再让你创作的时候
他的一个想象力的一种延伸
帮助更大
我举例来讲好了
像这个韵脚表有乌韵嘛
幸福道路或者说落幕
这个是很寻常的一个收集
那你可能就是去搜集那种比较罕见的乌云
可能像枯树哭泣的哭
述
说的数这个比较少见
但不是没有
你的韵脚用语越少见
然后你的变化会越多
但不是说一定要用
切记切记不能为了用韵而用韵
不能为了换字而换字
恰如其分
他在歌词的排列中刚好扮演一个关键性的角色
像这个韵脚表
你们仔细看
它总共有13种变化
13种听觉韵
这样子的一个选项排列已经够丰富了
基本上每一个听节运都可以收集一堆的资料库
再就是说比较分类
比方安跟安茶汤诶
茶汤这两个字就很中国风哦
悲伤是比较通用语了
就是说你可以把一些比较有画面感的
数据库里面
你再把自行分类
这样子你可能敲考的速度比别人快
或者说你一次可以教两首
我当初新人竞争的时候
曾经就是有时候一次交两手
然后最高记录是教三首
刚刚那个韵脚表我就不足韵的跟大家去做简介
因为三堂课已经分享一些了
接下来我用七里香来跟大家做一个解释跟说明
像七里香这首歌
它的歌名并不是副歌的第一行
但是因为雨下整夜
它这种用语很通俗
所以我并没有用雨下整夜
而用七里香这个植物的名字
他这个植物名有个很感性的说法
就是相隔七里还闻得到它的味道
开花的时候就叫七里香
隔了七里还闻得到花香啊
我就觉得这个好好特别哦
很有想象的画面
后来我就用七里香当歌的名字
接下来跟各位同学分享的就是韵脚
这也是同韵脚A耶韵
举例窗外的麻雀在电线杆上多嘴
你说这一句很有夏天的感觉
各位同学请注意哦
这种写法很心思
也就是所谓的诗歌
他的想象画面很大
而且上下两行的跳跃很强
你看窗外的麻雀
麻雀这个字也是我们歌词累积里面的资料库
比较不常用的
你可能会累积那种心碎憔悴落泪
但是麻雀是动物
是鸟类
他摆在这里是恰如其分
你别的情歌
你硬生生砍着一只麻雀
就很奇怪
所以呢记得窗外的麻雀在电线杆上多嘴
因为麻雀在户外的时候很吵
站在电线杆上叽叽喳喳叽叽喳喳
然后下面是你说这一句很有夏天的感觉
这种想象画面是跳跃式的
是很心思的语法
因为这个你是女生
他说在电线杆上多嘴接句
很有夏天的感觉
因为感觉让夏天很多植物啊
花卉啊
鸟类啊都会盛开
或是从南方回来
然后再来手中的铅笔在纸上来来回回
我用几行字形容你是我的谁
这个也是很心思的语法
再下一行
秋刀鱼的滋味
猫跟你都想了解初恋的香味
就这样被我们寻回
记得这是TL4的写法
就是说它下面一行一样有呼应上一行
但是他的呼应是以诗的语法跟结构
一言以蔽之
以最少的文字去表达最多的意思
就叫死鸟
那秋刀鱼猫跟她那个女生的
她就很可爱
然后都想要了解
然后初恋就像初恋的感觉
就这样被我们寻回
她跟她在一起
所以这个不是悲伤的情歌了
再来那温暖的阳光
像刚摘的鲜艳草莓
把阳光拟人化
当作鲜艳的草莓
你说你舍不得吃掉这一种感觉
感觉怎么吃
这个就是诗的语法
感觉只能体会吗
不能吃吗
所以呢像这样整首歌你去经营它的文字的结构
它的美丽必须整篇贯穿它的调性才会一致
我再举个例子
像下面的段落
我接着写
把永远爱你
写在诗的结尾
你是我唯一想要的了解她
不care外界的任何失误
他只想要了解这个女生
所以呢他把永远爱你写在诗的结尾
我把诗定义在歌词里面
所以它的丝的感觉的结构更明显
画面感更强
它比较会有丝的美感
或是换个词汇
它比较文青
比较文青
比较甜美
比较可爱
那再举那个词汇的收集
像麻雀比比较罕见
稻穗稻穗一般情歌你放不进去
除非你你讲到乡愁吧
否则你稻稻穗是放不进去的
但是季节冷却雨水是可以
然后撕的结尾结尾这两个字也很少用
画面感是饱满的
所以呢我刚才一直强调
我们的资料库收集的一些词句或片语
越罕见越好
甚至你可以分门别类
这是常用型的
这是比较罕见的
这种词汇好像比较适合写中国风的
你可以把它分门别类
这样子去整理
当做一门课业
好的
除了以数据库的形式去收集这些歌词韵脚之外
还有一种形式叫做写生
什么叫写生
写生法就是你要出去外面去场景
看到所有的场景抄录下来
这个好处是说你真实地感受到那个场景
像我有时候去经营文字结构的时候
我会把歌词的段落当做一个安排
有时候呢我就先经营空间画面感
再次写文字
再人称代名词
这个都是可以有变化的
你去创造这些语汇的时候
每一个创造你都有经验的获得
另外就是说设身处地去想象周遭的景物
譬如你去了图书馆哇
图书馆一定有台阶
然后一定有一个窗台
一定有木质的地板
这个就是视觉
你到了一个夜店很有飞镖坝
还有吧台
甚至有鸡尾酒杯
高跟鞋
这个就是环境的视觉的片语
就是你待到一个空间
一个场景
比如说你去校园哦
有荡秋千
有操场
有足力吧
有课桌椅
有黑板
有司令台
有白衣黑裙的学生
这些都是视觉视觉的片语
你肯坐公交车
公交车上面看到的乘客
司机接警
然后乘客可能有身份
可能是学生
可能是上班族
甚至你在角落会看到一个低头闷闷不乐的人
这个都是观察
就像去户外写生一样嘛
写生的意义在于说你把眼睛看到的景色
用素描笔或水彩把它还原出来
绘画的练习嘛
写生那数据库你可以在电脑里面
近期可能的打关键字
写生是场景式的收集
就另外分类
因为场景式的收集他的画面感比较集中
调性比较统一
这个很有帮助
像当初我写上海
1943我没有去过上海
写完之后的隔了好几年才过去
但是我去搜集资料
因为有某种程度把歌词创作
当做电影脚本去经营
你要拍一部旧上海的电影
你要熟悉那个时空背景
那里的风土民情
那里的场景
那里的语言
那里的族群
那里的城市的结构
那对我而言
上海是一个城市面貌很丰富的地方
它有租界
有外滩
有弄堂
有石库门
有法朱雀
有梧桐树
那个整个城市的面貌是很丰富的
然后我去搜集资料的时候
那时候我没有办法做场景的收集嘛
因为我没去过
我就觉得诶吴侬软语
那个年代人的讲话的一种语气
因为老上海的画面感
还有黄金阁春联
这些就出现在我的歌词的结构里面
消失的
1943是个年代
是个战乱的年代
所以那个战乱的年代
眼睛看到的应该都是一些有岁月感
有怀旧的色调的一些遣词用语
上海1943这首歌他整个调性就是怀旧的
因为你的年代已经定在1943
一开始
泛黄的春联还残留在墙上
依稀可见几个字
岁岁平安
初年去对那个岁岁平安
他的岁月感就出来了
在我没回去过的老家
米缸爷爷用楷书写一个满
这是一种习俗嘛
然后接下来是黄金葛
爬满了雕花的门窗
只有老建筑才会有雕花
这是小细节
夕阳斜斜映在斑驳的砖墙
斑驳又呼应的年代
铺着榉木板的屋内
还弥漫姥姥当年酿的豆瓣酱
我对着黑白照片开始想象
记得年代感一定要统一
那个年代就只有黑白照片
爸和妈当年的模样
说着一口吴侬软语的姑娘缓缓走过外滩
吴侬软语是那个时空背景
那个语调
最后的副歌是消失的旧时光
在回忆的路上
时间变好慢
老街坊小弄堂
是属于那个年代白墙黑瓦的淡淡忧伤画面感
老街坊小弄堂另外一段的副歌是消逝的旧时光
1943回头看的片段
有一些风霜
老唱盘
旧皮箱装满了明信片的铁盒
里藏着一片玫瑰花瓣
这些都是很有画面感的
与时它会让人家进入那个年代感的一种情绪
一种想象
所以呢有时候歌词你可以经营年代感
可以去强调他的空间
有些歌词不需要像倒带
基本上他的情绪用语比较多
画面感比较少
像这样子的搭配
你要灵活的运用
因为我很喜欢收集东西
所以我收集这种单字啊
片语呀
或是分门别类
我自己有一个资料库
但是有时候赶着写东西
像之前出差
可能在飞机上写
可能在酒店里面写
那基本上那个都用不到
后来我比较没有依赖的
就是初期跟中期还是有
因为已经养成一个训练了
你的这个已经变成你的技术的本能了哦
今天要写乡愁的
那我就想到说哦
茶汤江南这样子的词汇跟乡愁是吻合的
今天要写都会感的哦
可能说霓虹
然后或者说夜空诶
霓虹跟夜空哇
整个情绪就进来了几个关键字
画龙点睛
会把整篇歌词的意境给引出来
创作的时候就是这样子
你要有能力去经营画面感
你要有能力去布局
你要拍一部旧上海的电影
你要收集资料吧
青帮洪门杜月笙十里洋场
像百乐门一个舞厅
还有和平饭店
这些就在那个时空背景
它是并存的一个城市的结构
你去搜集资料
或是你去养成习惯
整个画面感的调性不会出格
像你去经营一个很浓稠
有岁月感的一个调性的歌词
他就不适合出现很突兀的字眼
你明明里面有江南有茶汤
然后有风霜
有斑驳的砖墙
然后突然卡一句手机就很突兀了嘛
基本上这种错误不应该犯
那另外就是说没有去过的地方
你还是可以经营他的画面感
去搜集资料
但有时候会出现一些小错误啊
呃蔡依林的一首布拉格广场
我就写下许愿池
你知道吗
我想说西方的广场应该都有许愿池嘛
他就对着许愿池许愿嘛
结果后来有人去了布拉格
说说我骗他
布拉格广场根本没有许愿池
因为我没有实际上去嘛
我就是收集资料
看
靠想象
但无伤大雅啦
因为他的画面感跟他的那种浪漫的感觉
都还是在
就是只差一个许愿池而已啦
也没有人说太讲究
今天分享的重点放在工具书
这个工具书一定要自己去收集
每收集一句
你就有一个记忆
那还分两大类
一个是数据库
数据库你可以上网去查
没有问题
一个是写生
所谓的写生就是场景式的收集
那我建议旅游
旅游是个收集资料很好的
因为旅游的状况下一定是放假
放假的时候一定很疗愈
心情一定很开心
一边旅游一边带个小册子去搜集诶
看到一个小镇哦
这边有一个特别的榕树
这边有个土地公庙
这边有个中词哦
这些词汇平常用不到
就把它收集
记得哦
主题式的收集
是要把这些遣词用语都集中在一个类别
不要打散
数据式的收集是用韵脚去当单位的收集
同韵脚在一起
不管他是什么类别
但是主题式的搜集是这个跟村庄有关
这个跟都市有关
这个跟夜店有关
这个跟历史有关
这种方法变成你有两本的工具书
一个是主题式的收集
一个是数据式的
数据式的就是以韵脚为主
主题式是以场景为主
这些工具书要自己去做
甚至于说你可能把它打字吧
装定乘车都可以
这样子的好处是
你手头上有自己亲自整理的工具书
这样子的工具
据说对创作者而言是受用无穷的
因为当你累积的创作越多的时候
你很害怕重复写
有时候我就遇到这种困境
我每一首出去的歌词内容
都必须有一个新的结构跟故事线
你写了那么多中国风了怎么办
所以你有这个资料库的话
你就会避免避免说哦
上一次是偏乡愁的用语
然后再上一次是偏江南的
然后这次我要写古镇
因为你有主题式的收集
你就不会自己给自己找麻烦
创作会有瓶颈的
所谓的瓶颈是你怕陷入重复性的语境
你怕重复自己的结构
那这样子主题式的收集会避免帮助你
避免可能你写过了乡愁
写过了古镇
写过江南
这是写京剧
现在是写书法相关的
因为有你有主题式的收集
那这个会帮助你回避掉这些困扰
因为有时候很漂亮的句子你突然写下来
因不太可能啊
通常要酝酿啊
而且我写歌词哦
慢的话
有时候写一两个礼拜
甚至还有超过一个多月的
两个月的都有
因为你是逃避嘛
逃避压力是人之常情
但是切记你逃避了当下去做别的事情
你的逃避就有意义了
比如我把歌词搁这
我可能去写个专栏
或是我把歌词搁这
我可能去参加一个讲座
或把歌词搁着
我再写一本书
就是你用不同的工作类别去逃避压力
烟酒是会累积后遗症的
你烟抽多了
酒喝多是有问题的
那另外一个不要讲逃避哈
舒缓另外一种舒缓压力的方式
去看一场电影
看一个舞台剧
或是跟朋友吃顿好吃的
就暂时隔离那个创作的空间
那很有用
比如说你明明就写不出来
就先搁着
而且记得哦
创作的时候
千万不要从第一行的第一个字开始写
绝对不要很多作曲的老师
有时候一开始从副歌开始写的
副歌漂亮了
他才去前面铺成a one跟A2
很多时候都是这样子哦
那我们作词也是这样子
也可以这样子
你把最漂亮
最有记忆点
最好的创意留在副歌
特别是第一行跟第二行那个是精华
是反复记忆的地方
所以创作歌词的时候
绝对不要从第一行的第一个字开始写
万一写到第三行卡住了
你整首歌都写不下去了
所以呢你可以从副歌开始写
那副歌实在写不下去了
好像结构里面有哪里的问题
我的建议是用刚刚那个方式去做别的事情
做完的时候回来再继续进行
那另外一个方式是继续进行
但是你是跳段落写是可以的
你最后交出去的是漂亮的
是拿得出手的就好了
问题是你还没交出去之前
你你a one写两行
跳到副歌
写三行是没有关系的
整个通篇的歌词最后整理的时候很重要
你要有节奏感
就是最有意义
最鲜明的记忆点必须出现在副歌
你不能一开始的句子很漂亮
在a one
然后大楼副歌那个用语很浅显
很很无聊
甚至很口语
甚至很常见
那就这这首歌就可惜掉了
就可惜掉了
所以切记创作歌词的时候
绝对不能像跑步一样从头开始跑
你可以有想法就写哪一段
然后再跳着写
最后的整理是最重要的
你让整个歌词的意境
故事线合理饱满或是顺畅就OK了
各位同学记得亲自整理
好好的执行我们课堂上所有的要求